foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
hi Piers Morgan I'm censored tonight 24
hours at rocked Russia and could still
change the world are we witnessing the
beginning of the downfall of the world's
deadliest dictator and can you crane to
impute his chaos into victory
also to make calls to ban Adventure
expeditions to the Titanic after the
Titan subdisaster claimed five lies
should explorers have the right to tour
the ruins or debate that with the
descendant of victims of the original
Titanic voyage
that's wrong John is hell for his
show-stopping final show in Glastonbury
Festival two real rock stars need an
autocue to read their own songs we'll
debate that
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored good
evening for London welcome to Pittsburgh
and Center for years we've been told
that Vladimir Putin's a tactical
Grandmaster with an iron grip on power
an unshakable truth in a world of
uncertainties who can Outfox the west
and crush the center home all before
Judo at tea time but the world is
changing before our eyes and so is his
that illusion has now been shattered
Putin's world could literally be falling
apart this weekend a column of Rebel
soldiers came within 200 kilometers of
Moscow they shot down Russian
helicopters in a plane forced the
military to destroy an oil Depot then
seize control of a Russian military
headquarters those soldiers weren't part
of some Western plot they were Russians
part of the mercenary Wagner Army led by
afgheny pregozip who launched the
biggest assault on Putin's power that
he's ever experienced and Russia's
dictator normally so careful to manage
the propaganda or state television was
seriously rattled
all those who deliberately went on the
path of treason for preparing an armed
Rebellion
terrorist attacks will be punished
inevitably
well that didn't happen
the Wagner Rebels met little of any
resistance in some places they're even
cheered and celebrated by other Russians
a panicked President Putin lined Moscow
streets with troops and dug up Rose to
the Capitol so that the city's residents
were told to stay indoors of work on
Monday cancel and Weber goes in the Mad
Chef agreed his deal to stand down the
Rebellion he was even cheered of fist
bump as he drove away we don't know yet
why he made that deal or what it all
really means or whether he'll survive
the Fallout himself exiled apparently in
Belarus what we do know is that Russian
troops were killed and military hardware
destroyed on Russia's own soil by a
renegade Russia militia and they've also
far been released without any punishment
at all in fact goes into these popped up
with a self-aggrandizing audio message
claiming he showed Putin how it's done
foreign
Putin on the other hand today failed to
even mentioned the failed coup in his
first statement since the country sat on
the brink of a civil conflict before the
war in Ukraine that would have been
Unthinkable before this weekend it would
also be not thinkable now it seems clear
that Putin's demented quest to build an
Empire by invading and destroying his
neighbors threatens his own very
survival this was a plot From Within
These people know where he sleeps and
where he hides his own people saw him
humiliated and exposed Putin's iron grip
has just turned well to jelly the
question now is can he cling on well
joining me now is former World chess
champion and chairman of the renewed
democracy initiative Gary Kasparov
Ukrainian ambassador to the UK vardham
price sticker I'm sorry I said I care
former head of the British army Law
dannett plus russia-born author and
broadcaster Constantine kiss it okay
well a great panel first of all uh Gary
Casper let me stop thank you for being
in the studio I'm greatly appreciate it
what's going on
you're a chess Grand Master can you work
out what's it play here there's a cheers
Grandmaster I'm used to analyze facts
and I believe what we saw was a tip on
iceberg is so much still underwater I
don't think Pringles acted alone I think
that was a much bigger challenge to put
into Power by those in Russia uh mostly
Gru or KGB who were not happy with the
world Ukraine don't forget Russia is a
mafia State and there's so much money is
at stake and Putin basically is a
liability for those who have been doing
this business with hundreds of billions
of dollars maybe we should look for
answers for previous operation in Africa
I mean we don't know enough but what we
know is that Putin's regime looked at
the facing first real challenge as a
Hollywood decoration just big
decorations nothing behind it so Putin
made a big statement you show the
statement nine nine a.m it's it's in the
morning who followed his orders nobody
what was the government nowhere to be
seen Parliament Senate a Ministry of
interior minister of defense they're all
gone so it's just you know it's it's a
colossal song on on Clay feed and I
think what we saw was just the First Act
of the drama uh I would don't trust you
know the stories about these deals
because again I think there's so much is
behind behind the scene and it was all
about I believe commercial interest but
what is important is the way pregosian
troops were received by Russians I think
it's more more about corruption because
the the name of the precautions
operation was March for justice and I
think that's this it's the people
instinctively demonstrated it's uh
that's the this corruption regime uh uh
this puts his regime as as no support as
it claimed the whole story of Putin was
popular has been just you know destroyed
by by the March which stopped for no
clear reasons percussion could be could
could have taken mostly in the next 12
hours none of it really makes a lot of
sense General Danny we've just been told
the Russian State media reporting that
Vladimir Putin will make a series of
important announcements this evening
that'll be his first appearance since
announcing the Wagner Mutiny what's he
going to say what what do you think is
going on here well be interesting to see
what he is going to say because on
Saturday morning he had a lot of words
but he didn't have much substance at all
and looked like a man pretty much caught
in the headlights so unless he's
reinvented himself something clever I
think we're going to see more more of
the same I think whichever way you look
at it he is now a weakened man and what
pragosians extraordinary sort of March
for justice towards Moscow showed was
that person's got very little support
where was his army an Army in an armed a
mutiny situation like where were they
can do one of two things it can oppose
the mutineers or it can do nothing they
chose to do nothing right and this
actually speaks volumes even the uh is
it the beginning of the end of Putin
historically with Russia when this thing
happens this kind of March if you like
or assault on whoever's running the
country tends to be the the end pretty
quickly
um I think it's very much related also
to what is going on in the battlefield
in eastern Ukraine and I think that's an
extraordinary set of circumstances the
counter-offensive which has been talked
about for a long time well-equipped
well-trained well prepared
um a lot of preliminary operations have
been going on there will come a point at
a point in time and space I don't know
where or when when the Ukrainian forces
feel they've found some weak spots and
that's when they'll press with their
attack brigades and then Anything Could
Happen how do they've diminished
militarily are the Russians in Ukraine
right now without the Wagner group well
they are diminished because the 25 000
also fighters that were fighting they
were fighting side by side with them in
Bachman until they've withdrawn so
numerically the Russians are are weaker
also the senior command and control from
General grazimov down that's now got
question marks over it how much
Authority can he actually deploy and
then of course you come to the Russian
soldiers themselves most of them don't
really want to be there right they're
poorly equipped poorly trained very
poorly LED at low level yes they've got
wonderful defensive positions but if
they can if those defensive positions
can be cracked into then frankly
Anything Could Happen literally and it
would only get overly optimistic and
lives are involved here Ukrainian lives
are involved here well although possible
they could break through and be very
successful yes I agree uh Ambassador
bristaiko I mean I can't even imagine
what your weekend was like I was gripped
to this literally watching cable news
the entire weekend
what were you doing
same I was wasting two days of my time
or weekend quite rare thing just to
understand what is actually happening
how it can influence what is happening
in our part well I can tell you that for
us both of them is a precaution or put
in both of them are enemies we
understand that the the when there's
fighting it will is a situation in our
case at least this 25
000 people or six more helicopters will
now appear in Ukrainian Skies so that's
what we were hoping what was interesting
also it was not very well reflected that
what progression said before starting he
went and making I'm just interrupting
you invested one moment we now have live
pictures of Vladimir Putin he's actually
talking yet we're going to keep an eye
on this this will be an interesting
statement it's it's come actually uh the
Press service for the Belarusian
President Alexander lukashenko has
written on telegram a lot of questions
stuffing versions and assumptions the
first one will tell everything answer
everything very soon follow the agenda
again some cryptic messaging coming out
of Belarus there
what do you make of that I hope that
we'll talk now about the minister of
defense or chief of defense and if it is
the part of the sort of the agreement
with preggers
remember he went to Moscow saying that
he is going to undermine the particular
two individuals not the Putin himself so
he was living certain flexibility here
but having Luka shanken picture they can
talk now about the even glow sort of
deeper unification between Belarus and
Russia they might tell it's so volatile
of of course on the face of it my first
thought was this looks good for Ukraine
that in just as you're launching a
counter-offensive you have the Russians
in total chaos of course knowing the
character of Putin it could be the
reverse he might decide to double down
in Ukraine to go even harder more
aggressively that's a potential right I
agree I agree with it was Gary that
there are some circles in Russia which
will be more interested some of them are
not happy with what is happening it
doesn't mean that it won't go
unescalative and higher and the
oligarchs nothing can be done in Russia
without a regards or consent so what
they want what they want to you know to
get rid of sanctions or they wanted to
finish it up right now right away so
let's escalate let's finish it up
whatever the consequences let me bring
in Constantine guessing Constantine
you've been tweeting away about this the
last three days fascinating actually to
get your take on this how are you seeing
things as we well we're watching
Vladimir Putin about to make some
addressing what he's going to say but
what's your take on it well some very
good points have been made so far the
one thing I would add is I think uh
people haven't emphasized enough the
fact that anybody who's going to attempt
to replace Vladimir Putin is likely to
be more nationalistic and more Hardline
than uh him at the moment as you know
over the last quarter of a century
Vladimir Putin has removed everybody
who's attempted to challenge him uh from
a more liberal or more Democratic
position one of those men is sitting to
your left
um Gary Casper of course and uh so what
I think people forgot in the west is
there's no Nick Flagg waiting in the
wings to take over this is a very
serious situation this is a nuclear
Nation uh with the potential for civil
war so I wouldn't get too excited about
it even though of course we would all
want to see uh Russia less powerful in
its uh terrible invasion of Ukraine so I
think that's one of the things to add
and the thing that is happening right
now on our screens is Vladimir Putin
giving a statement I imagine we will see
him attempting to reassert Authority
because what we have seen over the last
many days is that his authorities
certainly in question yeah I'm not sure
Gary you've been shaking your head this
I'll come it's absolute nonsense I mean
it's total misunderstanding of the
nature of any dictatorship after 23
years Putin is a spine of the system you
cannot take spine away and put someone
in the place whoever comes after Putin
will start negotiating with Americans
with ukrainians there's no no doubt
about it it's that's what's happened
after Stalin's death so you cannot have
another dictator of basic Putin because
he's the center of the series making
process and now it seems that he's no
longer Capital he's not a final referee
in all all these negotiations between
various groups so that's why it's like
you know saying oh shaufenberg also
brought some questionable people with
him and after Hitler who could have
somebody worse no absolutely not but if
you take your mafia analogy for
argument's sake in the mafia if the head
boss got taken out they would replace
him with often somebody even worse it
takes time before before you have
somebody else they have to negotiate
it's more like a politburo which always
better because they have to enjoy what
do you really think in your bones is
going to happen here Gary oh I think
it's this it's this this growing
opposition to Putin's to Putin because
he's losing the war there's a huge
commercial interest that is not
interested in to continue unwillable War
they know this war cannot be won and
again what will be the outcome of this
fight I don't know but I don't think
Buddhism will stay for too long because
if Russia history is any guide the bad
words always led to the change of the
regime ambassador
what does Victory look like here is
there any potential as some people have
called for Ukraine to cede any of the
territory that the Russians have taken
or is your position still implacable you
do not give them an inch
that is a position that we are not going
to give an inch to anybody and Russians
the first and second I'd like to say
what about Crimea for example which was
taken years ago for me as well you'd
like to see that I'd like myself that's
true and by the way we already started
to liberate some of the places which we
are under occupation since 2014. not
just a recently acquired a lens so that
that's that's what we are already doing
did you feel total Victory is now very
achievable in fact potentially a lot
more achievable than it looked last week
much better now that's true this jar was
the with the spiders in it you know who
will get out of it will be wounded and
will be weakened I totally agree and if
you want to you're talking about the
analogy historical analogies if you
remember when the garbage got back after
the coup it only took four months until
the whole system collapsed afterwards
we've got this some some uh quotes now
from Putin tonight General Janet I'll
bring this to you the organizers of this
Rebellion he says cannot but understand
they will be brought to Justice everyone
understands this that is Criminal that
is aimed at weakening the country from
outside we are threatened over the
organizers of this Rebellion have
betrayed those people who were bribed
into this organization so he's saying
apparently also the society has
Consolidated so much evidence of that
but he's he's suggesting from that
unless I'm misreading it that the Wagner
group have betrayed Russia and they have
to be dealt with but there's no sign
from the vaginal group that they're
fearing not going to happen well he said
that on Saturday morning that these
people were brought to Justice by
Saturday evening he said that they would
um be allowed to go their way so he's
now reverting to his first speak
um what do you believe what do you
understand I mean I think um uh he's
lashing out I think he's showing further
signs of weakness by holding completely
differing points of view is he done
Putin do you think I think he's done and
go back to what I said before I think
when the Ukrainian Army's counter-attack
uh really gets going then I think he
will be completely done and I think the
big point of the battlefield to remember
is that if they do vanished if the
Ukraine has managed to break in and
break through they haven't got to defeat
the Russian army everywhere they've just
got to make the average Russian soldier
think he's lost and when an army thinks
it's lost it's lost and that's what
they've got to try and Achieve and they
can do that some more quotes here
Constantine I'll bring you in here a
Putin most of Wagner are also Patriots
he closed his speech by saying president
Erica shenko also the Belarusian
President should be thanked for his role
in this to achieve a peaceful resolution
it's a patriotic duty of everyone that
has saved us thank you so some kind of
mixed messaging although I guess what
he's uh trying to say tonight is that
the organizers are the culpable ones uh
what does that mean though what's he
gonna do well as I said as I predicted
he was going to attempt to read a
certain Authority but on the other hand
he doesn't want to make enemies of 25
000 of his most capable soldiers who are
quite loyal to getting precaution as far
as we know but I think there was a
misunderstanding about the previous
point that I made I wasn't suggesting
that uh a coup would make Putin stronger
what I was saying was that a lot of the
resistance to uh to the regime at the
moment isn't actually focused on
Vladimir Putin a lot of the criticism is
of his defense minister shoigu and the
head of the Armed Forces garasimov and
that I think is where this has all come
from this conflict has been brewing for
many months now with a war of words
between pregosian and the ministry of
defense and so what I I was saying and I
think this is important to say the
liberal Democratic voices like Gary uh
have been forced out of Russia and so
much of the resistance to Vladimir Putin
isn't people who want uh democracy and
stability it's people who feel that the
war is going badly as he says and they
want someone to come in and take charge
so uh we it remains to be seen this one
actually plays out yeah apparently just
reading some reports on Twitter here
that apparently he said the uprising was
doomed to fail and his organizers even
though they lost their sense of right
and wrong couldn't have failed to
realize that he also seemed to say that
Ukraine was involved somehow and calls
the Revolt revenge for their failed
counter-offensive he then ranted about
Wagner's treason a bit more and then it
cut out he didn't actually announce
anything so someone on Twitter here uh
Gary what do you mean of that
mad rentings yes it's just I think he
lost control and probably feels that is
this uh he can keep talking but nothing
is happening and uh what you just said
now just doesn't make any sense no none
of it makes sense no do you think he'll
still be in charge in a month's time
months maybe uh definitely not within a
year probably you know three to six
months Ambassador what do you think it
will be bloody it will be dirty but he's
going down
General and there might be a churn
someone might replace him and then
someone might replace that person I
think the second replacement could be
more favorable to the west and just the
final Point general what message does
all this send to China who may have been
considering attacking Taiwan is this a
marker in the sand that if you do this
kind of thing as a dictatorship that
actually can backfire pretty pretty
horrendously the Chinese should think
very carefully about taking on the world
over Taiwan actually the Chinese were
patient people just give it time
um they would be most unwise to take any
lessons out of this if there is a lesson
actually it's a coup such as
such as Putin tried to mount on Kiev
24th of February last year it did not
work so just don't go there General
Ambassador Grandmaster great to see you
all thank you great panel tonight
Constantine thank you as well for
joining me much appreciated a lot going
on in Russia a lot going on in Ukraine
going to be fascinating a few days and
months to see how this all plays out
well on since the next
wreckage
in peace after five people died in a
catastrophic implosion of the type and
some as it tried to reach the Shipwreck
we'll debate whether extreme tourism as
it's done should now be banned
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
sub tragedy continues to divide opinion
with descendants of the Titanic tragedy
in 1912 saying it's time to let the
wreck rest in peace others say all
Extreme Adventure tourism like this
including deep Dives and space
exploration needs far greater regulation
to avoid disaster but must continue
those on the other side of the debate
including Boris Johnson argue that all
goes against the spirit of events of an
inspires Humanity to ever greater
discoveries what do you want to me to
discuss this is Titanic is still in
Shelley binder whose great grandmother
and great uncle both survived the ship's
sinking in 1912 and by the biologist and
television host Jeff gorwin who is
currently filming fishing in shark
infested waters and is no stranger to
Adventure and exploration well thank you
both for joining me Shelly binder first
of all tell me about your relatives who
survived the Titanic sinking
right well thank you for having me
Pierce
um my great-grandmother was 18 years old
and was bringing her 10 month old baby
Frank Phillip or Philly baby Philly to
meet my great-granddad who had come over
in September of the of 1911 to emigrate
to the United States and her parents
said if she waited three months they
would agree to make up the cost of the
ticket in order to send her over on the
safest ship ever built
and that's how she ended up on the
Titanic right incredible and and your
great uncle was also on board
yes he was 10 months old at the time
correct and they actually got separated
in the in the sinking
so just to Clara sorry the great uncle
was of course your great grandmother's
child there is that what you're saying
exactly my grandmother's brother and
what then happened
to both of them
um well
um on the Carpathia
my great-grandmother was despondent and
wouldn't get off of a mattress lying
down and you know she thought her baby
had been thrown overboard
and finally after a couple of days it
was quite stormy on the carpathio it was
a four-day Journey back to New York
after several days they convinced her to
go up when the weather broke to walk her
on the deck which she did and out of the
corner of her eye she saw a baby
reaching his arms toward her of course
he knew that was his mother because he
was still breastfeeding
and she said that's my baby and the
woman who was caring for him was an
Italian lady who didn't speak much
English so a crewman said take both
women and the baby up to Captain
Roshan's cabin and he will decide the
issue so Captain rostron played King
Solomon in deciding whose baby that was
and as a witness bearing witness to this
scene were the three ladies that Captain
roster and had staying in his cabin they
were three ladies from first class from
the Titanic who were all recent widows
from the Titanic Madeleine Astor
um Marion Thayer and Mrs Weidner and so
these three ladies were witness to this
uh Solomon moment that he had and of
course she identified some birthmarks
that the baby had and so he gave the
baby to her and melon Aster then said oh
your baby looks cold and took off her
scarf and wrapped it around my great
uncle and uh gave her a five dollar gold
piece
amazing what incredible story so then
let's come full circle to what happened
last week the tragic events of the
submersible what is your view about
wealthy people paying 250 000 to go down
to the wreck of the Titanic where your
relatives have this miraculous survival
I do uh send my condolences first and
foremost to all five of the gentlemen
who lost their lives on that submersible
and to Ocean Gate who
um is suffering as well through this uh
you know I've talked to many of my uh
Titanic historian friends
and I've also spoken to other
descendants of Titanic
survivors and also descendants of people
whose family members did not live
and it's interesting to note that their
opinions differ somewhat about whether
Extreme Adventure tourism is applicable
or appropriate in this situation and the
people whose relatives died on this ship
almost universally that I've spoken to
think it's a terrible idea and are
who seem genuinely offended by it that
this was happening but it's it's
interesting to note and I'm sure you're
aware of this fact that Stockton Rush
the CEO of Ocean Gate his wife Wendy is
the great great granddaughter of Ida and
Israel Strauss who both perished yes on
the Titanic amazing twist yeah so that's
an interesting coincidence yeah very
amazing twist so I'm assuming by that
that she didn't have any problem with it
I guess we don't yeah we don't know that
um yeah I mean Jeff it's a complicated
one isn't it because it's had a lot of
backlash I personally think and I've
said this pretty vocally the last week
that I think that what makes this world
great are people doing extraordinary
things like and you know these kind of
Adventures exploration history seeking
and so on uh there are others who say
it's just a ridiculous thing for very
rich people to be abusing the ocean in
this way where do you sit with it
well it's interesting Pierce it's um
you know human beings we are hardwired
to be explorers all the incredible
technological innovations that we have
in our lives today all the incredible
discoveries have come from exploration
especially when it comes to the Seas but
I'm in my boat right now and I'm
actually commercial fishing taking a
break to speak with the you guys and uh
I have a responsibility I have to follow
the the laws and the regulations of of
the sea or I can be held accountable if
someone's on my boat right now and they
get injured it's going to be my fault
so I think there's these are it's almost
apples and oranges
yes it's wonderful to explore and
discover and share that with humanity
and with something as sacred as the
Titanic you need to do it with an
incredible amount of foreverance and
respect and hopefully some Enlightenment
learning but if you go there
haphazardly and expose yourself to
Jeopardy
there can be the ultimate price to pay
for that and we may have seen that with
this vessel
right with this uh submersible right
Shelly
um I heard that your great grandmother
was so traumatized by what had happened
to her that she never really recovered
and that she would never get past the
sound of people dying in the water and
screaming out
yes she uh went on Robert Ripley's Radio
Show in 1939 and she spoke about that
and she also spoke to my father in 1960
and was quite upset and pulled him aside
and said that she could never get that
out of her thoughts out of her head the
sound of
1496 people struggling and dying in the
water of course it was extremely painful
because the water was about 27 degrees
and it felt like knives being thrust
into you so many I mean most people the
majority of people did not drown but
they froze to death and it was a
horrific uh thing and she could never
really get past that in fact she spent
11 months in and out of a hospital
trying to
gather herself with what she describes
as a nervous collapse and of course 11
months after the accident my grandmother
was born right I mean of course there's
this horrible irony that these people
who paid the money to go down on the
submersible to see that the wreckage of
this uh iconic ship they themselves
suffered a a horrendous death I mean
hope we can only hope and pray it was as
instant as the experts believe it it
probably was but a horrible irony
nonetheless thank you both very much
indeed uh for joining me Shelly and Jeff
I really appreciate it thank you
thank you pierce well on sense of next a
Curious Case of the dog that's been
canceled but not celebrating pride month
that dog and its owner join me live next
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
this is talk TV
welcome back to Facebook when I sent it
I'll introduce you to Bella Bella's a
three-year-old dog who was rescued by
her owner Jonathan Miller I bumped it to
Jonathan at Royal Alaska on Friday and
he mentioned that bed is likely to have
become the only dog in history to have
been canceled and it's because of pride
month well I said too Jonathan you
better come on to Piers Morgan
downstairs and explain this
extraordinary story with Jonathan and
Bella welcome to Piers Morgan and
sentencing what happened
well it's uh I was in London last week
as you know we did have the pleasure of
seeing each other and I was uh we have a
little flat in London I live in France
and I was struck by the ubiquitous uh
branding for Pride everywhere I went to
Tesco it was a pleasant with uh with
pride Flags Regent Street uh Pride the
pub next door Pride everything was pride
and it I began I'm sorry I'm a bit of a
grumpy old guy I guess but it struck me
as being Slightly bizarre why is there
such a thing as pride month we give one
day a year to Veterans who died if any
of their country A Day to mother as a
data fathers maybe a couple of days to
Jesus but a month for Pride anyway at
this moment I received an email from a
company called attractive in Austria
which makes a GPS tracker which lets me
keep an eye on Bella as she hunts in the
uh in the vines every day for green
lizards and wild boar and and long it
has and the uh the email suggested that
I should order a um a rainbow flag
um cover for Bella's GPS device so that
she could uh show her pride in pride
month and uh I'm afraid I was triggered
and I robbed the ground for me I'd
rather grumply wrote uh to attractive in
Austria and I said why don't you just
concentrate on tracking dogs and uh and
cease the virtual signaling which I
thought was a
and I got a reply that said uh we've
taken thank you for your email it was a
very passive aggressive reply thank you
for your email we've canceled your
subscription to uh to attractive so you
can no longer track your dog so
um being the uh the the evil journalist
that I am I maybe thought well this is a
good story I wrote it for The Spectator
got a huge reaction
um and you like the story too
um and you've now had an apology
then this morning
um the story continues that is possible
is bedtime she's a little little that
first live television show
um I get an email from the Chief
Executive Officer of attractive Apollo
Bella's going to jump down and so you've
seen him you've seen all you're going to
see it fella
um I get a an email from the chief
executive fact of apologizing you know
you know rather rather humbly and saying
that the person who canceled me had no
right to do so
um and that they'd indeed do respect uh
other points of view he said that
attractive continues to support uh Pride
which I guess is a right
um but all is well that ends well and
that fella can continue her gradations
in the vines without fear of becoming
lost should she be distracted but it is
an extraordinary situation I think I
think you hit the nail on the head and
it's not about not wanting to embrace
the spirit of pride of course I I do I'm
sure you do it's why is there a whole
month of it why is it all so completely
over the top and why if you raise any
raised eyebrow even about your dog
having to embrace this then you get
canceled oh no that's it your dog can
die sorry it seems to me that uh that
this thing has has spun slightly out of
control and corporations in particular
and governments have embraced this as if
um
lgbtq XYZ or whatever it now is is some
kind of ideology and I I don't really
understand why it should be so sacred
um and I don't even actually accept that
lgbtq
Etc is really a community I I noticed in
the King's Birthday honors list which
was published a few days ago
and in which Mrs Miller my wife featured
um there was an award that was an award
given for services till the to the
lgbtq community I mean what really I
mean it's not really a community the
elves don't seem to get on particularly
well with the G's and the t's don't seem
to get on particularly well with many of
them that's true
um and and uh it's not certainly you
know I have gay friends and have had for
years I've had gay colleagues I have
absolute respect for gay people they can
do whatever they want but this kind of
in your face ideological Push by
corporations and governments to identify
with this strikes me as excessive and
not really
um proportionate given that there are
many many deserving I mean I gave my day
okay I've been a gay pride month um I
said I I totally agree I think it is
over the top now and I don't like being
forced to do anything
um and I think what happened here was
you were basically told if you didn't
you know if you didn't go along with
this your dog would then be put in
danger have its tracking turned off I'll
read out a statement from Michael uh
hunas he's the CEO attractive he's
allowed to apologize one of our support
agents felt personally targeted relative
no matter he shouldn't have shouldn't
have happened we have internally taken
appropriate measures I want to emphasize
that we do not share your view but we do
accept different opinions I'm not even
sure he really knows what your view is
I've reinstated your service and added
three months of free service but an
interesting little twist there whether
he doesn't agree with your view it
presumably thinks you're homophobic
because if you don't agree with
everything that is laid down as law on
this stuff uh by the mob then you become
transphobic homophobic whatever it is
I'm none of those things I suspect
you're not either but continue to raise
eyebrows Jonathan because thanks to your
going public Bella has been uncanceled
Bella has been uncancel that's correct
and she's a very happy dog and it's past
her bedtime and probably past mine
I won't keep you any longer Jonathan
what a pleasure to see you again last
week and uh we'll talk again soon it's
great to see you thanks for coming up
take care bye thanks extraordinary
extraordinary State of Affairs one sense
of next from Lewis Capaldi fighting hard
to stay on stage to Sir Elton John using
an alter key to remember his own lyrics
I'll give my uncensored verdict on
blasphemy next
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
and next up on the talk Harry and Megan
are slammed as work shy by Netflix and
Spotify bosses meanwhile Prince William
wants to end homelessness and the mother
of the teenager killed on the Titanic
tourist sub says she was supposed to go
on that vessel in his place and Saint
Paul's Cathedral repents after calling
Winston Churchill a white supremacist
that's all coming up for you at nine
laughs
[Music]
talk about two Facebook nonsense and
welcome to my Pat Kevin McGuire
Associates of Delhi mirror talk to the
contributor Esther cracker and by talk
to you presenter Rosanna Lockwood
Glastonbury uh somewhere where I think
hell begins and ends being in a tiny
little tent surrounded by the stinking
masses of Glastonbury with their pink
hair and nose rings is my idea of 80s
however I'm aware that it is popular
with a certain type of human being and
there were some awesome pretty
extraordinary moments over the weekend
there's a little taste
[Music]
it is
[Applause]
so two are probably the most
extraordinary moments there Rosetta one
Sir Elton uh look I'm not his biggest
fan really it felt a bit karaoke to me
the whole thing if I'm honest it was a
good old show but the bit that caught my
eyes when he was reading his own song
lyrics on an auto queue and he did it
the entire duration of his performance
it reminded me was that Sinatra's last
gig in London he was caught reading the
lyrics to my way so I think my point is
if you actually have to read the lyrics
to your own smash hits should you still
be performing or is he right now to hang
it up uh so you and me peers it might be
throwing stones in Glass Houses
attacking people for reading Auto
[Music]
exactly and look he's plus 60 now it's
his last gig I've I watched the entire
thing I sort of had it on the background
whilst I was scrolling my phone on
Twitter as usual and it didn't grip me
until the finale until Rocket Man but
you know it I just find when they wheel
out what I can call the golden oldies a
Glastonbury they don't put on as hungry
a performance as some of the younger and
the newer have you said that he got
record TV audiences record crowd turned
up I mean that's you can't knock I mean
and I think there's also just on
longevity alone yeah so I'm doing a bit
like Paul McCartney last year and these
these guys the ones who write the songs
right these iconic records for five six
decades you gotta hand it to him I mean
he would draw a huge audience making a
cup of tea so that's that's a given yeah
I do think that when an artist reaches
sort of Icon status they need to be
protected like an egg do you know what I
mean they shouldn't have any viral
moments where they look at it I mean
Mariah Carey has status yet
I wouldn't mind being pretended like an
egg
yeah but I think like people like Mariah
Carey and you know just the greats just
just just preserve them because you
don't want them to have viral moments in
this era of the internet and of meme
culture the internet is unforgiving well
I'll tell you what was fascinating uh
the the lowest Capaldi thing so Lewis
Capaldi suffers from Tourette's yeah and
he got an attack of tourettes coupled
with severe anxiety when it happened
understandably and he literally couldn't
sing so you got this massive star at
Glastonbury huge crowd and I know a lot
of people in his position would have
just warmed up yeah acute credit to him
but what was extraordinarily moving was
the way the crowd filled in the gaps and
began singing recognizing the struggle
he was having took him along because
they know he had spoken about it
publicly he took time out before
Glastonbury so everybody is on his side
I saw the park life in Manchester last
year and he's a fantastic performer he's
a great showman brilliant Talent oh and
uh it's like it's Elton John he is he
just need to be protected he's 76 so he
doesn't remember the way he used to and
people make uh make allowances for that
and if you go to Glastonbury would you
go have you been no I've been to other
other festivals I don't mind yeah
of course you have a liberal tense
I think is a steal for what you get you
get almost four days of some of the
biggest acts in the world and I do not
agree with knocking this Festival yeah
Festival I've never gone to a stay in
the tent two things happen one the ten
are the four man tent with one mate and
it burnt down on the first
spend the entire three days in a one-man
the secondly uh Charlene was top of the
build remember Charlene I've been to
Paradise but never been to me and number
six on the bill you know I managed to
see by pure charts were a young
up-and-coming Irish band 1981 I think it
was you know they were YouTube six on
the bill to to uh Charlene Cliff Richard
was second number six you two what
happened I was there yeah pretty cool I
was
the green belt Christian rock festival
anywhere because all the best village
all members of the church
yeah it wasn't really a religious thing
um so let's talk uh secondly about this
amazing clip I love this the Belgian
shot putter called jolian bonquo right
now she took part in the European
championships and the hundred meter
hurdle what's it here she's the one at
the back
laughs
but it took her 19 seconds
right and you might think on the face of
it how utterly embarrassing what are you
doing how did you ever get near the
hundred meter hurdles at a European
championships but you know the reason
she was doing it is brilliant
if she knocked him
except she would be deducted points
right and the reason she's running
even though she came last by Miles was
that the other two Belgian hurdlers had
to pull out from injury if no one
competed in the event the team would
have been disqualified so she stood up
and went brilliant I'll do it yeah it
was great knowing she'd be a viral
mocked but I don't think she is people
have loved her everybody loved them
Australia I think before because people
understand why she's doing it it doesn't
actually look ridiculous it's great and
she said of it I don't take myself too
seriously it comes to sport which I just
think is it's for a professional athlete
I think she's a quite a heroic person
for doing that she should challenge all
the others to a shot put
I just want to play another clip the
gear changes this is Barack Obama
talking about the uh Titanic uh
submersible that's what he did by
comparison
oh have we got it
not sure we have got it
maybe we can find it here we go and the
next day they sent someone out to survey
her yard so that isn't it that's
obviously not Barack Obama unless Joe
Biden is now identifying as bracket bomb
a black man well you can do that these
days
here we go here we go
there's there's a potential tragedy
unfolding with a submarine that is
getting
you know minute to minute coverage all
around the world
and it's understandable because
obviously we all want and pray that
those folks are rescued
but the fact that that's gotten so much
more attention than 700 people
who
sang is
[Applause]
that's a
that's an untenable situation we've only
got a minute on this but Rosanna I mean
he makes a point it's a lot of people
have made that point is he right to make
the comparison I think we absolutely
have to have that conversation we know
why the submarine story caught
everyone's attention it's Unique it's
about it's interesting people can relate
to it they perhaps can't relate to being
a migrant but I think if you don't have
that conversation then there's something
terribly wrong going on in the world
because just stand back it's five people
it's 700. Esther the argument goes the
migrants were trying to travel somewhere
illegally blah blah blah but is that a
Humane argument well it's not and you
have to understand I mean you're right
people can't identify with it you have
to imagine how desperate those people
are to risk their lives in that way and
I think that's something that we have to
remember it's there's something
Barack Obama yeah I think yeah should we
be throwing the kitchen sink next time
not at 5pm the submersible of their own
volition but 700 people drowning I see
why the five people in an iconic wreck
was a big story but we didn't cover
enough seven or nine people I think the
answer is you can do both uh thank you
back that's it for me tonight whatever
up to uh we'll keep it uncensored and as
Adam would say in terms of Breaking My
Heart
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]